pourquoi faudrait-il vacciner les
enfants jean michel claverie ben c'est
pas à moi qu'il faut le demander parce
que je milite depuis pas dans quelques
mois contre totalement cette vaccination
en pensant qu'elle est inutile et même
d'ailleurs contre-productive je ne
comprends pas par exemple que gandais
dans des classes de maternelle ou dans
des classes d'enfants très jeunes se
déclarent un cas de co vide positive
donc en général l'enfant à des appels
malades où il a le nez qui coule on
ferme la classe à mon avis ce qu'il
faudrait faire ses marques regardez la
classe laisser les enfants faire leur
immunité naturelle avec cette maladie
extrêmement bening et ça rajouterait à
la population française de qu'une
fraction de jeunes qui seraient
immunisés et qui seraient amusés langue
de molière pas non plus efficace que par
le vaccin parce que plus au long de plus
longue durée est plus résistante aux
variations parce qu'elle est dirigée
contre la totale et du lyrique totalité
des virus et pas seulement une seule
protéines vaccinales je pense que c'est
vraiment une erreur importante que de ne
pas laisser les enfants faire leur copie
en qu'il dans leurs points et ne pas les
embêter avec des vaccins dont on ne sait
pas encore et jeunes insiste là-dessus
elle est effectivement la dangerosité
parce que les quelques articles qui ont
été publiés sur ce domaine sont des
articles qui sont on peut le dire
essentiellement bâclé qui ont été très
fait très rapidement qui porte sur
quelques milliers au maximum d'enfants
et je le papier qui fait principe qui a
été publié dans un des plus grands
journaux médical a suivi les enfants en
moyenne 57 jours après la deuxième dose
je n'estime pas que ça soit un recul
suffisant pour estimer que ces vaccins
ne sont pas dangereux pour les enfants
qui eux ont des maladies extrêmement
minime
[Musique]